of course we've been talking here with
uh vin diesel whose new movie amana part
is in theaters today our next guest is a
bit of a surprise is actually his
brother who's also an actor ladies and
gentlemen please welcome leonard diesel
let's get him out here
[Applause]
great uh leonard good to have you oh
this is great great to have you here
leonard
yeah oh thanks it's i'm sorry it's the
same night i feel like no
comfortable yeah i can come back another
night this is no no no it's good that
you're here now you're here now and you
might as well uh be here now you okay
you're doing all right
yeah everything's all right yeah
okay now uh of course everybody around
the world are you comfortable you're
fine you seem uh yeah the sip of water i
guess okay
yeah okay uh everyone's familiar with
your brother vin huge international star
what about you what kind of movies uh do
you do
uh
i'm uh i'm an action star too
yeah so really
yeah uh i mean i i got a movie uh coming
out
also i don't want to be
i don't want to be rude
i just have to say leonard you don't
really seem to have the temperament of
an action star you don't you don't seem
very uh aggressive or self-confident
yeah that's true
uh
i mean
like off-camera on that you know i'm not
very confident or assertive
but i have a thing where like when the
cameras start rolling then i can just
like turn it on you know and then turn
what on just like
badass quality sort of
you know just like then you know this
isn't that leonard was always the
tougher brother really okay this is this
is hard to buy but you know if vin is
saying it's true it's true a weight
bloomer okay
okay well let's uh you have a clip here
i want to see this this badass side of
you yeah all right well this is uh this
is a clip from my movie that's coming
out uh it's called a poison cat
and uh
and uh
in this movie i've been uh
contracted by the the cia to recover
their secret plans that have been stolen
and uh here it is and this is your move
okay let's take a look at this clip from
uh
poison cat poison cat yeah
well if it isn't el gato what do you
want
the laptop
what laptop
the laptop you stole from the cia
we didn't steal any laptop so you should
go
oh
i could in
in uh
still still up there no
that's weird because the
the guy that said that they stole that
well we did not
do you um
think maybe that like you took it uh by
mistake
yeah
i don't understand
good
help
hello
uh if you find i can leave my number and
then if you find it
you know it called me
[Applause]
more
um i'm listed under elgat though if you
find it turns up
wow that
was was pretty riveting nothing
that was hot just like him you know
yeah here
vince seemed worried now he's got some
competition
it's over for you yeah all right well
good luck to you thank you leonard for
being here we'll take a break uh our
thanks also to vin diesel again we'll
take a break shannon doherty coming up